mais d'abord à l'activité de l'aéroport
de Tours redécole avec l'arrivée du
printemps depuis ce week-end les
fréquences des liaisons vers Londres
Porto Marrakech Marseille ou Dublin
s'accélère en 202280 000 passagers ont
foulé le tarmac tour en Jau un chiffre
qui pourrait être boosté cette année par
la venue à tour de l'équipe irlandaise
du 15 du Trèfle lors de la Coupe du
monde de rugby alors doit-on s'attendre
à une vague verte en provenance de
Dublin dans les prochains mois on tente
d'y voir plus clair avec Clémence dose
retour de la liaison entre Tours et
Dublin à l'aéroport depuis ce weekend la
ligne transporte une vingtaine de
milliers de personnes chaque année des
vols directs appréciés des voyageurs
leur évitant d'aller jusqu'à Poitiers ou
à Orly nous allons voir notre fille qui
habite à Dublin depuis 13 ans s'il y
avait pas cette ligne sur une contrainte
d'aller à Paris nous habitons
Loir-et-Cher la ville visiter les musées
et puis voilà puis les pubs surtout on
peut partir de Tours donc c'est pratique
aussi la liaison est fonctionnelle de
mars à octobre un calendrier qui
s'aligne avec la Coupe du monde de rugby
en septembre prochain l'équipe
irlandaise est en accueilli à tour nos
voisins d'outre-manches sont à faire le
déplacement
la ligne tour Dublin pourrait donc voir
sa fréquentation augmentée grâce aux
supporters de l'Ovalie un phénomène
similaire à celui de l'Euro de football
en 2016 en 2016 nous avions euro de
football surtout avec énormément notre
surprise d'ailleurs énormément de
passagers irlandais de supporters
irlandais qui étaient venus supporter
leur deux équipes qui étaient engagées
dans dans l'euro donc là on a l'équipe
d'Irlande de rugby qui est basé sur
Tours la première nation mondiale on a
une ligne sur Dublin donc on peut être
raisonnablement optimiste pour
effectivement les accueillir et faire
vivre la ville de Tours et le centre Val
de Loire hors événement sportif les taux
de remplissage des vols sont d'environ
90% à l'année la fréquentation des
prochains vols entre l'Irlande et la
France et déjà au beau fixe